foreign
all right it's uh it's past one o'clock
uh 104 and uh we are scheduled to do a
division three orientation I'm sorry I'm
late I was talking to the speaker about
something vastly important I got an
update on our room
yeah yeah
yeah so
um so I I have a little bit of an agenda
I want to talk about and I I know that
Mr Ripple is probably come prepared to
give us an education so we'll start with
him and we'll do some uh some odds and
ends at the end
but for the division three folks we have
both extreme experience and extreme lack
of experience so any question anybody
wants to answer ask we probably have
somebody here who can answer it so
um so just think of this as a kind of an
open Forum an open opportunities for us
any uh questions or concerns you may
have Mr Ripple do you want to give us a
so I guess first of all uh for the new
members my name is Kevin Ripple and I've
been with the LBA
I started with the audit division in
2007 and I've been with the budget
division since 2013 and division three
specifically since 2016 2017 so a couple
budgets worth of experience there
um and your Phil feel free to contact me
at any time phone email stop by my
office I can tell you where that is and
I'll be glad to help
so
typically for these division
orientations we start off with sort of
an overview of
in the case of the other divisions the
various agencies that you oversee and in
the case of division three the various
divisions within HHS and normally we
would go over the budgets for those
divisions some of the big issue areas
Etc but
I talked about this with some of my
co-workers beforehand and typically what
we find is especially after the two hour
morning presentation people people's
eyes tend to glaze right over a little
bit so we're going to skip that this
year and I think I'm just going to talk
briefly about the process for division
three and again for those of you who've
been on the committee before there's
nothing new here
um
but I'll just go through it for the sake
typically the um committee starts its
work in Earnest or the division starts
its work in Earnest on February 15th
when the governor's budget comes out
this time we're going to start things
off a little bit earlier than that at
representative Edward's suggestion as
you may have seen in your email Janet
scheduled some division meetings on
January 23rd February 1st and February
3rd and on those days HHS is going to
come in and talk about selected issue
areas so on the 23rd they're going to
talk about
I.T systems and priorities and I believe
they're going to be joined by the
commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology for that
presentation
and then for the subsequent uh dates
they'll be talking about in no
particular order
Manpower and Staffing the status of
mobile Behavioral Health
the status of operations at Hampstead
and New Hampshire hospital
the status of operations and contingency
plans for Glencliff home
they'll be talking about public health
they will be talking about performance
metrics and how those are conducted
throughout the department
and they'll be talking about any ideas
they have for how to pay for employee
pay raises and or hiring incentives
so I think you have a sort of a full
schedule of some major issue areas that
HHS will become coming in and talking
about so that'll give you some
some good ideas for where to focus once
the budget process gets going in Earnest
yes so are we going to be able to pull
Meredith tell us before the 15th of
February or were we thinking that she
would come have to come after the
governor's budget so I conveyed that
request to Nathan and my request was
that she'd be
he'll be here
she'll be here on either the first or
the third okay so so to talk a little
bit about uh what Mr Ripple just went
over is last year or two years ago
rather was the my first term in division
three and one of the first things Mr
Ripple asked me is okay how would you
like to sequence the budget
presentations nice and I said I have no
idea you just do them in whatever way
make sense so so now having gone through
it I was left with the feeling that uh I
had allowed a lot of wasted time between
the beginning of the term and the 15th
of February and so what this is really
an attempt to do is to bring some issues
forward
with the disclaimer and with the request
for us not to really focus on the money
let's talk about the programmatics let's
talk about the issues uh let's talk
about the trends the concerns you know
that that sort of thing and also while
we're talking on these specific uh
strategic topic areas for lack of
another term
as you get questions that you would have
liked to have answered you know you can
either just ask them and say when you
come back during the budget phase you
know bring some answers to the following
questions I I don't think we should
expect that they're going to have
numbers or dollar numbers for us but I
do think they ought to be able to talk
about the programmatics because you know
they're they're on a trajectory they've
been on for years so so the antenna is
to to bring some of that orientation to
the department forward and and we'll
still do the hardcore number issues
later but but this is meant to be a
chance for you to ask questions of them
so that they come prepared after the
15th of February yes sir
no I
I'm done
just a quick question can you request
other presenters that they provide the
electronic versions of their documents a
okay now so some of the outlines of what
we're going to ask in the Strategic
topics
um uh Mr Ripple and I've talked about
them uh representative erf did some
heavy lifting on what those topics uh
some questions for those topics back in
October and sent them to miss Ripple
back then so so for the to bring me up
to speed
I I'm thinking of what representative
erf was asking of the Departments which
was more detailed than what I've been
asking and I'm just curious how you see
us aligned in terms of our one face to
the Department
well I'm I'm not really sure I conveyed
that request uh that representative erf
had made and I also conveyed your
request that the department at least
include the um schedule two forms that
can be found in the agency budget
request to the extent that they apply to
the governor's recommended budget so I
think at a minimum their presentations
will contain that
super and then representative nordgren
you had sent me an email saying that you
had some specific issues that you wanted
to address with the I think uh
glencliffe the sununu center and
and the New Hampshire hospital were the
three the areas that you were
and I think I think we are we being
broadcast so we should be using the
microphone
um so and I think Phil Brook was the
question
what's happening
I I think we can ask about Phil Brook I
think uh that is to me that's new I I
must have dropped the ball I don't
remember asking about Phil Brook but I
don't think so but we can ask the
department to add it to the
presentations on February 1st and 3rd if
you like yeah okay thank you
all right and so sorry among the other
among the areas that representative
Nordman had asked about I think the only
other one that wouldn't be covered by
the Department's presentations is the
sununa center
um and it's my understanding we can
certainly ask them to come in and talk
about that too but it's my understanding
that there's a special committee that's
addressing that as well so I'm not sure
if he wanted that to be taken up in
division three oh okay so
the sununu center because per statute it
needs to close on one March uh I I've
been working very closely uh as have
others like representative Lynn
representative Pearson to uh to prepare
a bill for the Senate to Fast Track to
get it over here and as I was talking
the speaker one of the things we talked
about was how we were going to Fast
Track uh the new bill through the house
and so I'm I I probably know as much
about that topic as the department at
this point because the ball is really in
the legislators legislature's Court to
get something passed and um and so just
for for those of you who participated in
the debate last year
you'll remember that the committee
conference produced a sununu bill
we did not end up agreeing to the sununu
bill primarily because the issue of how
big the thing should be there was a
strong advocacy for no more than six
there was another advocacy for minimum
of 12 that could be expanded to 18
should there be an exigent need for it
um and that caused the thing to break
down
at the same time when the bill was in
division three I had prepared an
amendment that had a number of smaller
points like Leverage co-location
leverage shared services what should
happen to the property at once um the
the residents were moved out
a number of topics the Senate last week
had a joint HHS and Judiciary Committee
hearing were they considered sb1 Sharon
Carson's bill I brought in the remnants
of what I had prepared back in May or
June for the sununa bill that just never
got considered never I couldn't get it
so so they've amended the bill to where
I'm really very happy with it
they're going to vote on it in the
Senate tomorrow I think it's going to
pass then it's going to go to Senate
Finance Senate Finance Senators Abbas
and Birdsall have some financial and
other issues with it so they may want to
amend it yet again so but but the Senate
knows they've got to pass or something
and get it to us quickly
once we get it it'll be assigned to
Children and Family Law
um the speaker and and representing
Pearson's the chair of that so I'm
talking to him but but what the intent
is is to get the right people from
division three to sit in with children
and family law so that the committee
will take one bite at the Senate bill
get it to the floor and pass it if we
pass with the Senate passes
then it's ready for the Governor's
signature and we can beat the one March
deadline
that's probably way more answer than you
wanted but do is is that does that
address your concerns about where the
I wanted an update on where we were with
the process knowing that we had the
merch first deadline and everything yep
thank you
um you're welcome
so do you remember where you were at I
do yes
so
you'll have those presentations at the
end of January early February and then
February 15th or thereabouts the
governor's budget will come out and the
trailer Bill House Bill 2 should come
out at the same time in the past there's
been a couple weeks lag getting House
Bill 2 out of the governor's office but
in the in-house Bill 2 from a couple
years ago there was a section requiring
that it also come out on February 15th
so you should get that bill to work on
right after the governor's budget comes
out the governor will present to the
full finance committee along with side
his budget director
and then usually in the week that
follows certain agencies including house
and Health and Human Services will come
in and give a presentation to the full
committee and then the division's work
will begin in Earnest
um so you've probably taken a look at
the calendar
and you see that the divisions have
about five weeks after the governor's
budget comes out to complete their work
it might look like a little bit longer
it might look like six weeks but the LBA
needs time
once you've made your decisions to make
the changes in the state's budget system
and put together what we call a detailed
change sheet and the other information
that you will need and that
representative Edwards specifically will
need to present on the division's
recommendations to the full finance
committee
so that's the long way of saying you've
got about five weeks to complete your
work so so I had heard Mr Kane say that
our division three drop dead date is 23
March is that is that what you heard is
that the the date we're going to
consider where division three should
have its work done I don't work on the
calendar in front of me but that sounds
about right
I'll verify with him but that sounds
so
speaking of House Bill 2 uh one thing
that I wanted to mention again for the
newer members is that
although House Bill one is a lot of work
for division three HHS comprises about
43 percent of the Statewide budget House
Bill 2 is a little bit less work out of
470 sections in the last trailer Bill
HHS comprised about 30 of them so at
least in that respect not to minimize
the the importance of House Bill 2 and
some of the sections in it but at least
in that respect your workload will be a
little bit lighter than some of the
um
you will also as the budget process goes
along have bills to vote out a division
last I checked there were seven bills in
the full finance committee only one of
which is in division three which is your
sununu Center bill
but there will definitely be more coming
so that brings me to what can you expect
of me and what can you expect at the LBA
office more generally hold that thought
sure let's talk about
um two things that I I learned last term
and this is specifically for the newer
people here and if I'm saying it wrong
I'd like the more experienced people to
correct or extend or revise my remarks
but
um
hb2 is
really very critical and what I didn't
know we should do and what I'm thinking
needs to be done is we need to
um I need to make a more concerted
effort to bring hb2 items to the
division early then we had them brought
so that we can discuss them and debate
them and probably if there's an area
where we're going to have the most
disagreement it could be over
potentially hb2 items so so because that
could potentially be a source of
contention it's my intention to try to
accelerate
um at least bring forward you know the
most critical hb2 items so that we have
an opportunity for everyone to discuss
it State their positions think about it
and and to work with Mr Ripple to create
amendments now are are you going to talk
about your firewall policy
on how you know okay so let me see what
I think your firewall policy is and then
you can tell me if I'm right or wrong Mr
Ripple works for all of us okay to the
extent that
um he gets overwhelmed that's kind of my
responsibility to try to you know set
priorities if need be
um but if you have things you want him
to research
um uh if you want amendments you want
him to craft uh that's none of my
business
it's it's strictly between you and Mr
Ripple until you're you choose when and
how to present your information
the one thing I would ask though is if
you know that you're asking him for
something that's
we're going to want to hear in public
hearing you know just kind of give me
the courtesy to know so that I can
prepare my head for you know what we're
going to do for work that day I don't I
don't need to get into into much other
than
you know uh representative nordgren
might say hey by the way you know we
have an amendment we want to discuss can
we schedule when we're going to discuss
it you know I I don't even particularly
need to know the details beyond that but
so so Mr Ripple is um
was it Austria that was the neutral
country uh he he sort of uh always
neutral always secure you can always
talk to him and in the two years that
I've worked with him I've never even got
a hint that there was leakage of
information that wasn't appropriate so
um
did I say anything wrong you want to say
any more oh I don't think so uh that's
very true yep any any request that you
make of me anything that you come to me
with I'll keep it keep it between us and
I won't share it unless less requested
Kevin I wondered if you'll be preparing
if the LBA will be preparing the
document that you've prepared for us in
the past where you take House Bill 2 and
you divide it up among the three
divisions and then each division
concentrates on their parts of House
Bill too yes we will do that so uh in
the days or the week or so after House
Bill 2 comes out the sections will be
divided up by division and you'll get a
chance to
look at the ones that are allocated to
division three and then shortly
thereafter John Williams most likely
will come in from HHS and talk about
those sections and then any requests
that he or the department has that were
left out of the governor's version of
house bill 2.
um
so
in terms of House Bill 2 as well as the
operating budget and any other bills
that come your way typically for
amendments you would go through OLS
but in this case you're welcome and in
fact it's probably easier for all
involved if you bring Amendment ideas to
me and then I can work on them and
complete them and forward them to OLS as
necessary so in the case of house bill
one anything numbers related typically
doesn't even go through OLS I'll prepare
a
a spreadsheet or a document that
includes the changes that you would like
to make and that will be handed out to
the full committee to vote on in the
case of host Bill 2 and other bills
they will be formal amendments that have
gone through OLS
um but I find it works a little bit
better if if they all start with me as
long as you're willing to do that if
you'd rather go to OLS first you're
certainly welcome to do that instead
um
so
as you suggested representative Edwards
I think we should get started on House
Bill 2 early as soon as it comes to the
division and probably have a couple
different run-throughs over the next few
weeks so you'll hear about amendments
that HHS would like you to make and
you'll have your own ideas for
amendments and you might even have ideas
from other bills that you would like to
incorporate into house bill too so we
can talk about that and prepare
amendments as necessary as we go along
um
sure so
so to the extent
that the department has hb2 items that
they are comfortable talking about
before the 15th of February I'm fine
with that is I think that's what you
were implying is that if if they're
ready early we can start early uh well
the that makes sense I'm not sure
they'll be ready early though because
they won't necessarily know before the
15th what the governor put in and what
the governor left out
which is true not only of the trailer
bill it's true of house bill one as well
foreign
amendments is one of the things that I
can do for you I can also conduct
research as requested if there's
something you'd rather come to the LBA
for instead of the department I'd
certainly be happy to do that and
um
I'll be tracking all of this information
as we go along so I'll be tracking your
requests of the department I'll be
tracking your requests of me I'll be
tracking the status of House Bill 2
sections that you've addressed and that
you haven't addressed and I'll be
tracking the areas of the budget that
you've addressed and have an address and
I'll provide you regular updates SC or
status as we go along so the committee
will never should never really be lost
as to where you're at in the workload
and what you have left to do
um and then once the division finalizes
its budget work in late March I and the
other analysts will get together
will prepare a packet of House Bill 2
amendments that have been adopted by the
division we'll prepare a detailed change
sheet which shows line by line all the
budgetary changes that the division
recommends to the full committee and
then we'll put those together into a
packet that you representative Edwards
will present to the full committee to
vote on in early April
so
that's actually about all that I had
planned on talking about today is there
anything that I missed or anything else
that you want to hear from
I I have I have some sort of
supplemental chair comments on on this
um
earlier today we we had a conversation
with Mr Kane about lapsing versus
non-lapsing and
um and so I don't think we need to do
that again just just for the committee
it's something we ought to keep an eye
on if the the Department's going to ask
us to change status from lapsing to
non-lapsing that that's going to be
worth a discussion
um I think as we go through this process
um you you probably know that Ways and
Means comes up with the initial Revenue
estimates and we can't by law spend more
money than we're told that is available
so Ways and Means has to produce
something that has to be get passed by
the house and then that makes available
all of the dollars for the division to
spend
as sort of a ceiling particularly with
the general fund
last year I was expecting the chair of
Finance to say okay we have you know
three billion dollars or whatever the
number is you know division uh three you
got 51 percent of it you know division
one you got some other percent I
expected an initial breakdown
to start our process we didn't get that
and I don't know I don't think we're
going to get that again maybe maybe the
vice chair could could speak to this if
you know anything about it but but the
way it ended up working last time
was that we independently did our work
and then we went back into the kind of
the finance committee of the whole and
that's when we started talking about you
know whether or not there was room at
the end or somebody had to start
thinking about cutting so so I I think
the first time through we should try to
be you know rational and reasonable
about what we're doing and then we we
may have to do some adjustments as we go
through that process
there are the footnotes those got
discussed earlier I I was naive about
how important it was to have a real
discussion about the footnotes and so so
I think I underemphasized that at least
for my own learning last time so so the
footnotes uh I've talked to
representative Mooney to help help keep
reminding me to bring those footnotes
forward so that we can discuss them and
then similar to that if there's an hb2
item that's tied to one of the
Departments obviously we're going to
talk about the HD hb2 item at the same
time
I'm going to tell you the major
challenge The Epiphany I had okay so so
some of you may know that I'm a
republican some of you may know that
what that means to me is that when I
look at the government spending uh I'm
I'm taking a look at programs to be
effective and efficient and to evaluate
whether or not the the money that we're
being that we're being asked to spend is
going to be spent you know well you know
we want to we we want to behave as
fiduciaries
so I thought this was going to be a
fairly straightforward analytical
process I thought we could ask the
Departments to come in and tell us what
their performance metrics were and we
could take a look at their performance
metrics as a way of determining whether
or not they were being effective or
efficient and and I I came to appreciate
that the the Department's internal
metrics are are not cooked they're not
ready for prime time so we're going to
have Meredith tell us come in and talk
to us about the status and I've told her
that it's not going to be a a gotcha
kind of exercise
but so on one hand we don't really have
the performance metrics to look at but
then and but then it gets a little
Messier because
we get so much Federal money and in
order to get the federal money we have
to match it oftentimes with General
funds and and then there's some minimums
that we have to meet and the like and so
what ends up is practically every
program from a money perspective has
this high level of intermingling where
if you try to pull out you know some
general funds you're pulling down the
the federal funds and there's a little
death spiral in there that some people
want to avoid so it's not as easy to do
a program a review and Analysis with an
appropriate budget
allocation exercise at least not in the
way I I tend to view it it's just a
challenge the other challenge is if you
take a look at a program and you say oh
look here's an FTE
I don't really think this is a
particularly great program I want to cut
that program well what you're going to
hear is well you know that's not really
an FTE that's that's uh that's uh that's
Joe and and Joe he works on four or five
different programs and so if you cut Joe
from that program he's still going to be
around for the other four programs so
you're really not going to cut you know
that FTE so it's just what I'm just
letting you know is it's going to be a
challenge for those of us who really
want to push on having a lean mean
Department
um and and that's and that's kind of the
reality is I see it of working with DHHS
uh representative Hull did you have
something you want to say I saw your
hand move I didn't know if that was
you're getting ready to throw something
at me or no thank you
um and I think the problems you just
mentioned are going to be further
compounded by
cares act funding and other funding that
has come in from the federal level right
significantly in the in the Health and
Human Services domain that is now either
created new positions or new programs or
and how do we extract out what was some
of those one-time payments so that we
can
look at that and say this new program
that got started under
some of these federal grants is this
something we want to continue those are
there's a lot of questions there because
we're talking
large sums of money
that came in in one-time grants
so so I I agree with you and I think
you've brought up
a related you know on tangent issue
which is there was a lot of one-time
money presumably for one-time programs
and at some point that Federal money
is going to go away and then somebody's
going to have to be confronted with the
reality of what we do with that program
when it there's no longer federal
assistance for it and and that that
that's going to be a tough day and I
don't know uh how much of that we're
going to see in this budget cycle but in
theory we could see a bunch of that
do you have any comments on that Mr
Ripple no okay
um so I I guess I would encourage each
of us to be oh I'm sorry did you have a
question
and I'm going to have to work on
pronouncing your last name I know it
starts with a t-e-l and you got a K in
okay
talinski
tolersky I'm I'm sorry
okay so representative Walling you
you've been down this terrain a lot in
division three is there anything I said
about the difficulty of uh unpacking the
intermingled nature of DHHS that you
would say differently or you view
differently
um well I think I think the department
has always been really
helpful to us in helping us understand
the mix of federal
money and how much State money we're
going to need so they and I think that's
something as a division we need to
always be reminding ourselves to ask
them for those details but they've been
really good about providing that kind of
information because there's a number of
things I mean they sometimes you need a
one-on-one match sometimes it's a
different mix of a match and sometimes
it's that you have to meet
you have to meet a level of funding
State funding from several years ago you
have to at least meet that
um so I think if we just work with the
Department closely on those things that
they'll provide the kinds of information
we need to really understand what we
have to what we're responsible for
funding and as far as the um
Federal money that's come in I think if
in fact there are areas that the
department
knows that there's funding mixed into
the budget
that was from those funds arpa funds or
cares funds I think they should alert us
to that I
um separated and that they're really not
mixed into the budget I think
at this point
is that right Kevin
just to cheat I see Mr White nodding
uh okay so representative did you want
to say anything in this
section about the intermingled nature of
DHHS and the challenge because because
you've really worked the spreadsheets as
well there's no doubt it's a challenge
as far as the R Pro slash covid funds go
those have all come through fiscal and
because in hb2 last time we were
prevented the addition of full-time
employees all of those are part-time so
they really don't show up in the budget
they shouldn't show up on the budget and
if they do then they should be new
positions that we should be able to see
basically so I'm not too concerned about
that
um
yeah it's uh it's good
well
as I've discussed in the past with the
chairman I had hoped that we would get
presentations from the Department that
really right up front tied
the programs
to the budget
to the success rate it doesn't sound
like that's necessarily going to happen
but I think that's really what we need
to be looking at in terms of trying to
okay do you do you Mr chair you have
anything you want to say in here about
your expectations for division three
well I'm looking down and I've been to
the other divisions briefly
um
I think you're you're setting up
hearings on like house bill 49. and I
haven't scheduled it for the full
committee yet because I keep getting day
by day more bills so I want to find out
exactly how many bills they had before I
set up the schedule
um so you're you're getting in it and we
talked in division two which has most of
these bills and they're kind of
looking at it as an oversight rather
than having the full hearing because
we'll have the full Hearing in the
committee anyway for all these bills but
if you're starting early then one of the
suggestions was just have the department
come in and give the oversight like on
49 what they plan what they've done and
so on because we may have a flood of
people coming thinking this is the
public hearing and you may get in your
case it's not as bad because you only
got the one bill but over there if
they've got six bills and they're trying
to do them all in one day and they get
flooded with all sorts of people that
want to testify
personally on things it's better to try
to just have set it up for an overview
by the department and then and then have
then have the public hearing here and
your people will be better informed
by the department of what what to expect
but we'll fill in everybody else on the
committee so that that's a little bit
different than the way we've done it in
the past but it's because of the slow
nature of getting all the bills to us
one other announcement I'd like to make
to the Republicans is when you're done
here about 2 30 we're going to meet over
here in 212 for a caucus and we expect
the
um
the majority lead it to be there so
I haven't got uh
full uh
confirmation yet whether he'll be there
or not but like to meet 2 30 with the
Republicans over here in 212.
do you want do you want to I haven't
mentioned it to anyone yet about
um
um on exact day uh having you present
yes when you want to exec make sure I'm
here I want to be able to participate in
all your votes I am an ex-officio member
thank you yes sir and then um if if exec
days are really important so if you
cannot be here
um if either Republicans you've got to
let me or uh representative Mooney know
and I would assume that the Democrats
want to let representative norgren and
and you perhaps as a fallback
do you want to say something to that uh
representative Northern
oh I got it
[Music]
um
okay so one of the things that I've been
asking about for the last couple years
and and that is
um as the department has come to to us I
have asked questions about whether or
not we see any inequality in our Health
Care system that we should be aware of
and that we should be addressing and I
probably asked a question similar to
that you know five to ten times and
almost every time I ask it the kind of
comments I get after the the committee
meeting is well why is he asking that
well I've been asking that to get my
head ready for a lot of the bills I
think we're going to be hearing this
year that will involve diversity
inclusiveness and equity and so so it
seems to me that in general based on
what I've been hearing over the last two
years New Hampshire is a pretty good
place in terms of making sure our Health
Care system works for everyone
and but I think we should all continue
to test that one of the things that I uh
that we heard during the joint economic
briefing was a professor from UNH were
you there still representative walner
when he presented I I thought he was
going to leave us those slides but those
slides apparently are proprietary and
he's not going to I'm going to have to
ask him for some of them but some of
them were excellent in terms of like
identifying very specifically where in
New Hampshire we have
um a kind of a disproportionate number
of the local demographic
qualifying for low-income or minority
status and so so I I I'm going to
continue to try to get
those diversity Maps because I think it
would make us all smarter when we we
hear about the concerns being brought To
Us by Advocates to ensure equality I
prefer the word equality to equity but
that's I won't get into that but but uh
we uh that we can all sort of be doing
our own sanity check and due diligence
to make sure that New Hampshire is a
good place for everyone to live
um I I just have a few thoughts on
decorum and
um we're going to be broadcasting all
the time so so
um uh this is a pretty professional
group and I think the
state expects a seriousness of their
finance and Ways and Means committees
and some other committees I just hope
that we continue to present
professionally to the public you know
because uh you know we're now more
visible than we were two terms ago so I
just think we should be careful about
that
one of the things that I tend to do
is when there's a person testifying and
somebody's asks a question
um mini chairman if not most expect that
the second or third question you come
back to the chairman say I have a
follow-up or I have another question or
you know there's sort of this uh
staccato back and forth that I I don't
really care for
so what I'm willing to do is if you
would like to ask questions if you could
just give me some idea like I I got two
or three questions I'd like to ask then
I would like you to just go have that
sort of question and answer without you
know being interrupted by coming back to
the chair because I don't that doesn't
add any value as far as I'm concerned
the value that gets added though is if
somebody goes off on a tangent and
starts asking too many questions or
something I I reserve the right to to
gavel and retake control of the Q a and
but other than that uh I'd much rather
sit here and enjoy a really great
educational conversation between the
legislator and the person providing the
testimony and not be thinking about the
you know sort of the format and the
rules and stuff I just as soon let those
conversations take place and um and I I
that was kind of the operating rule of
thumb last term and and representative
Waller you you were still incredibly
polite keep you kept coming back to me
to ask me for a second question and
stuff I just want to assure you I really
mean it this term if you want to just
you know continuing natural dialogue
that's perfectly fine and I think I
think last term I can only remember one
time maybe there were two times but I
can only remember one time where it it
got a little heated
and
um there was only one sort of bad gavel
moment and so so uh I I take
responsibility for that because it was
the first time I'd experienced it I
think I I was it behaved in my authority
but I probably didn't uh you know
what I did was okay how I did it was
probably subject to review but so I just
intend to just treat everyone with
respect I don't see us as a group of
partisans I see us as a group of
fiduciaries trying to figure out you
know how do we make these programs work
for our citizens uh and how do we do it
in a way in which we protect taxpayers
so
um those those are kind of things I
wanted to talk about are there any other
or the comments or questions uh yes Mr
clerk I want to acknowledge and thank
you profusely for accepting the vital
role of being our clerk thank you well
thank you for the invitation and it's an
honor and uh I guess it's been four
years since uh since you and I first
served on committee together I haven't
seen any instance where we've had to
bang the gavel and uh go against each
other uh if if it happens we'll get by
it but I don't expect it will I'm
looking forward to the work again I have
a question you mentioned earlier today
that um uh that you had a second
priority I think it was employment a
priority that sounds like a budget
priority
for the committee uh do you oh oh okay I
I'm I may not be responding on point but
um Mr Ripple to kick off listed like
eight strategic topics that we're going
to go over
we're going to try to start with it very
early on if not number one okay we're
going to take the Manpower overview it's
a very high priority if not number two
uh and and the rest of them are are are
in there and they're priorities because
we're going to talk about them
programmatically before the 15th of
February does that address your question
yeah I think so and so the things like
glencliffe and the New Hampshire
hospitals the input that you got are
things that you're kind of adding to
that list or integrating into that list
of what we're going to be doing uh and
getting a jump on before February 15th
right right so so by sitting in with HHS
uh to do uh to see that their committee
do the orientation that obviated having
us do the same thing with with DHHS
which gives us even more dead time to
fill between now and the 15th February
and that's that's where I think we can
do good work and and just look at the
programmatic levels without the dollars
associated
yes ma'am wait a second we have to we
to this is an eyesight test to tolersky
excellent perfect okay talersky thank
you quick question on
um your time management and scheduling
and how you handle it I know we got
notifications the division would be
meeting starting at 10 A.M uh two days
coming up maybe in
two weeks I'm just curious when we get
those notices should we assume it's a
morning and afternoon session or is that
specifically a morning session and a 1pm
meeting this time would be also issued
if we were going to be in the afternoon
that that's an excellent question at
this point you should have already begun
receiving division three Finance notices
um I know that the for sure February 1st
and 3rd went out as did the like the
27th or whatever that date is or I just
want to make sure I understand did you
get those or not I did and they say 10
a.m only and I'm just curious if that is
to be expected to have a full day with
the afternoon also initially these first
ones I don't think we could fill the
whole day because not the the we're
working around the department a bit and
so we're probably going to have you know
one or two or three of these sessions
depending on the ability of the
department to cooperate and coordinate
schedules with us so so I I think if we
if we start at 10 which is a general
good start time
um then
um we we could be done by 12 30
generally
and if we can't we'll recess go eat some
lunch and try to wrap it up
do you have any thoughts on that I mean
you're you're in Nashua yes right so I'm
trying to figure so representative
Stringham you're actually the one that
does anyone travel more than an hour
hour and 15.
so if we start at 10 o'clock
as a rule representative nordgren does
that give you plenty of time to to get
here do if we try to start at nine or 9
30 is that an inconvenience for you
so
um
yeah yeah I can't help you with 89. Mr
Ripple's good but he's not that good so
okay so for now I think we're going to
start a standard 10 o'clock and go until
complete and the first until we get to
the 15th of February those days are
all right
anything else
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman and why we have Mr Ripple still
I just wanted to take this opportunity
to just briefly discuss the budget LBA
tab of the website there is a huge
amount of information there which is all
very helpful is there anything in
particular you'd like to point out to
the committee or those that may be
watching that could be helpful as we
um
well I think you could take a look at
the previous session the 2223 budget and
maybe take a look at
one thing that I know you asked for and
that the committee might find helpful is
every two years the department presents
a briefing book uh that consists of
all accounting units with at least a
million dollars in them so that'll be
coming out for the upcoming budget
sometime after February 15th late
February maybe but you can take a look
at the one for 22 23 to get a sense of
what's in there and where the big
dollars are so that may be helpful to
look at
um
you can also look at
I'm not sure how helpful the Surplus
statement would be at this point but you
talked about lapse representative
Edwards the Surplus statement is a great
place to go to see the big picture not
just of HHS but the Statewide budget as
a whole to show you where the
Appropriations are not only in hb1 but
also in hb2 or any other bills to show
you the expected laps to show you the
projected revenues and sort of get a
sense of how that fits together for the
overall state budget so those are two
two documents that I might take a look
so this is uh kind of in the informal
times Mr Williams Mr White do you have
anything that you want to volunteer for
I don't know if we've technically met
you yet so
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Nathan white I'm the Chief
Financial Officer for the Department of
Health and Human Services
um I just didn't prepare anything formal
today was more just here to be a fly on
the wall but
um I think everything that that's been
said here has been pretty accurate about
the complexities of dhhs's budget
unfortunately with DHHS unfortunately
for for better for worse
um you know when when we do look at
positions or we look at programs
oftentimes there is a federal match
component
um you know for example many of our
contracts per se may have up to 10
various funding sources so we do braid
and blend funding to try to best
leverage the federal funds that are
available and The Limited General funds
so
um I I again I just want to reiterate
that everything that's been said around
that is certainly true
um Kevin was just referring to the
budget briefing book we are working on
updated budget briefing books and I'd
actually our plan right now is to start
to look at incorporating some of those
key outcomes and performance metrics
into that budget briefing book so that
we can have a document that's a little
bit more unified so that you can look at
the big million dollar accounts and then
within that that document is great
because it has here are the RSA
requirements that we need to consider
here's the population here's the
mechanism the delivery of service is it
Direct Care from HHS is it done on
um you know through through a contracted
service so forth and so on
um but what we're really trying to do is
update that and I've had a couple of
conversations with
um with representative erf about that to
try to make that document a little bit
more tangible to really tie the numbers
to the program uh and try to get away
from those presentations where we talk
about the program over here and then we
talk about the budget and it's really
hard to make those connections between
hb1 which on its face does not really
have a lot of description and and
supporting documentation to really
explain that so we are working on that
right now
we are also working on those
presentations that that have been
requested uh for
um the doit presentation initially and
then the subsequent presentations on
February 1st and February 3rd so
um that's a quick overview
um just a couple of General comments
um uh you know I I know that that Kevin
will act as the as the conduit for
members of the committee
um I will do my best to get any requests
that you have in as timely a manner as
possible
um we we certainly our department as you
probably heard we are at about 22
vacancy depending on the day
um so we do have limitations so so the
the if you're able to get those requests
in earlier that will just be really
helpful because I know that the budget
process it's five weeks it goes really
quick and to the extent that we have my
staff and my team uh and and the other
division directors so forth and so on
have time available
um to try to get answers for you as
quickly as possible
um that that will just help I think make
the process go better but again through
this whole process I'll be as candid and
open and honest with with all of you as
I can be please don't hesitate to reach
out if you you do have questions more
than happy to have any conversations
so so I want to just tell you that
you're stepping into some tough shoes to
fill I really appreciated working with
Karen rounds last cycle the thing that
impressed me about Karen was was even
when
something was a like a somewhere in the
department some professional little goof
up that they were fixing and there was
no dodging or hiding and you know it's a
huge organization so there's always
going to be room to fix little things
and so so what was nice about those
instances was knowing that she was being
transparent and honest because that sort
of sets the stage for some of the bigger
questions that we end up needing to rely
on the answer so
early on in the cycle I as a rule always
kind of went through Mr Ripple to the
Department
um I I gotta tell you though is we got
very close to that that deadline where
the division three had to uh is shut
down
um uh there were a lot of conversations
with Karen like the weekend before kind
of stuff and so so so I think the rule
of thumb is we'd like to go ahead and
use
um a proper uh coordination process and
just try not to create too much chaos
except that that gets imposed on us at
the end but
um your reputation is good you know
people I know who have met and worked
with you in the past they're all they
have nothing but good things to say so
looking forward to a great a great cycle
thank you I look forward to it as well
yeah all right
um with that I noticed there are a lot
of people in the audience this is
unusual for an orientation is there
anyone and thank you Mr White is there
anyone in the audience who has a desire
to speak to the committee tell us what
you want tell us what you need anything
anyone
you don't even have to fill out a pink
card
okay
um
so I think I think we're wrapped up on
our orientation
I'll take a motion
do we need a motion
a second
all those in favor say aye those
opposing a eyes have it we are adjourned
Republicans don't forget your 2 30
meeting